Okay,
welcome to the second part of,
uh,
of astro one 60.
Uh,
this is going to be about
black holes and relativity.
And,
uh,
just to give you a kind of a preview,
the whole point of black holes is
that of course they emit no light,
so you can't see them directly.
Uh,
and so the question arises,
how do you know that they're there?
And the reason you can demonstrate the
black holes exist is because they're in a
orbit around other things.
And you can see the motion
of the other things,
uh,
that interact gravitationally
with the black hole.
This concept should be familiar to a
certain extent because it's exactly the
same thing we've been doing
for discovering exoplanets.
You don't see the exoplanet directly.
Uh,
what happens is that there's something
else that you can see that's affected by
the presence of the exoplanet.
So the,
exactly the same thing happens with,
with black holes.
And so we're going to use,
uh,
the same equations,
the same concept,
uh,
to explore this very different contexts.
So,
uh,
black holes,
oh,
I can't be seen directly.
And so instead of detecting them directly,
you use,
uh,
this combination of orbital dynamics.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
things like the top layer shift,
okay.
To infer their presence and more than
just inferring their presence to infer
their properties.
Now the context is more complicated.
Uh,
and in particular,
uh,
we're no longer going to
be using a Newton's laws,
Newton's law of gravity,
Newton's laws of motion,
uh,
because there's a more comprehensive
theory that replaced Newton,
uh,
which is necessary to
understand these things.
And that more a complex theory is
Einstein's theory of relativity.
So we're going to be using some
relativity rather than Newtonian physics.
This gets weird very fast.
Okay.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so I'm not going to start there.
I'm going to start with a kind of
Newtonian explanation for what black holes
are.
We'll do that this time and then,
uh,
the weirdness we'll start on Thursday.
Uh,
so the first concept,
uh,
and the easiest way I think
to understand black holes,
uh,
is the concept of the escape.
Philocity
this is a piece of high school physics.
Some of you may have
encountered it before.
Uh,
and it just means how fast you have to
go to escape from the gravitational field
of a given object.
If you go outside and you shoot up a
rocket ship or something like that,
how fast do you have to shoot it up so
that it doesn't fall back to the earth?
And so that you can define an
escape philosophy for the earth,
uh,
or for any other object for that matter,
which is just how fast you have to
go to escape its gravitational field.
There's an equation associated with this.
It looks like this a v escape,
the,
that's the escape velocity to g m
over r all to the one half power.
Uh,
and uh,
this is the speed,
uh,
required to escape,
the gravitational field.
Yeah.
Uh,
and object.
Yeah.
Uh,
supposing that the object has mass
equal to m and radius equals to R.
Oh,
one other assumption.
I'm assuming here that you're standing
on that you start from standing on the
surface of the object.
Uh,
if you are
the surface,
okay,
this equation should look vaguely but
not a hundred percent familiar to you
because you derive something that looked
a lot like it on the second problem set
where you worked out the relationship
between the semi major access of an orbit
and the speed and object had
to go in to be in that orbit.
And what,
uh,
the way that calculation worked out,
it was velocity equals g m
over the semi major axis a.
So that too wasn't there,
uh,
in that derivation.
But otherwise,
the form of this is actually
quite similar to them.
So let me explain,
uh,
why that is.
Here's a,
here's some object.
It's got a radius of r and a massive m.
And imagine that you've got
something that you know,
orbit around this object,
but it's in orbit right above the surface.
It's just skimming the
surface of the thing.
Uh,
that would be impossible in the case
of earth because the friction from the
atmosphere which slowed you down,
but in,
uh,
a planet without an atmosphere,
this would be possible.
Imagine you're just sort of skimming over
the tops of the mountains or whatever.
So here you are in orbit.
This is something in a nice circular
orbit right above the surface of this
object.
And it's going around and uh,
it's got some velocity,
which I'm going to call
the circular velocity.
And,
uh,
as we calculated in the
previous section of the course,
that's GM over a,
which is in this case GM over,
cause you're s,
uh,
skimming the surface,
the one half power.
So that's how fast you have
to go to stay in orbit.
If you go slower than that,
uh,
let's take a different color here.
If you go slower than that,
you crash into the surface
right away because you don't,
you're not going fast
enough to stay in orbit.
So that's what happens in the case.
If you have a velocity less
than the circular velocity.
What happens if you're going
faster than the circular velocity?
Well,
you're going so fast that you move
further away from this object.
You don't stay skimming the surface.
So here you are going a little bit
faster and now you're not in a circular
orbit,
and your orbit ends up looking something
like this nice elliptical orbit.
Okay.
And this is a velocity greater
than the circular velocity,
uh,
but still less than the escape philosophy
because you haven't to escape the
gravitational a feel because
you're still in an orbit.
It's an elliptical orbit now,
but you're still in an orbit and
it'll come back to the same place.
Now,
if you're going at somewhat faster
than that at the escape velocity,
then you never come back.
You continue,
uh,
all the way out to infinity.
Uh,
your orbit continues to change direction
a little bit due to the gravitational
force of this thing.
You just continued to slow down.
Uh,
but in the end,
uh,
you never come back.
So it's a non repeating orbit,
and if you're going even faster
than the escape velocity,
uh,
then,
you,
uh,
get to infinity even faster.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and more importantly,
when you get there,
you're still moving pretty fast.
Uh,
this,
uh,
gradually slowed down.
So all of these different kinds of orbits,
but one that crashes into the planet,
the one that's skims the planet,
the one that's an elliptical orbit,
the one that escapes altogether,
those are all within a factor of the
square root of two of each other.
Because remember,
the escape velocity here
is equal to two g m
over r to the one half.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
just by increasing your or your orbital
speed by a factor of the square root of
two,
you go from being in a nice circular
orbit to escaping the gravitational field
of the object all together.
So you can calculate escape
velocities of things.
Uh,
let's do that once the
escape philosophy of earth
of earth,
that would be the escape is two g m over
r to the one half a to g is seven times
10 to the minus 11.
Uh,
m is for the earth is
six times 10 to the 24,
uh,
are for the earth is something
like seven times 10 to the six.
This all has to be taken to the
one half power sevens cancel.
What do we have here?
Let's see,
12 times
10 to the 13,
24 minus 11,
over 10 to the six one half.
Let's see,
that's 1.2 14 minus six is eight
times 10 to the eight to the one half.
That's something like 10 to
the four meters per second,
because I've used a,
the value of g that's appropriate
for meters per second.
So that's about a 10 kilometers a second.
So that's the escape
philosophy of the Europe.
If you go outside,
you throw a football up into the
air at 10 kilometers per second,
it's not going to come back down.
Try it.
Ah,
good exercise.
Okay.
Uh,
you could calculate
the escape velocity of,
of any particular object.
You can calculate the escape
velocity of each human being.
Uh,
uh,
a human,
a human has a massive 100 kilograms,
a radius of about one meter.
Uh,
this is kind of a big human,
but a,
we'll go with it.
Uh,
let's see.
V Escape is equal to two g m over a half.
There's a very famous book about physics,
uh,
with the title,
assume a spherical cow.
Uh,
and this,
so this is the kind of thing
that physicists like to do.
It's an idealized situation.
We have this perfectly
spherical human being.
Uh,
and uh,
okay,
so let's do the calculation.
Two Times seven times 10 to
the minus 11 times a hundred.
That's 10 to the two over one.
Uh,
did the square root,
uh,
that's a 14 times 10 to the minus nine.
Call it 1.4 times 10 to the minus
eight a to the half power that,
uh,
something like 1.2,
let's call it one,
one times 10 to the minus
four meters per second.
Or,
uh,
let's see,
that's one 10th of a
millimeter per second.
Uh,
that's less than one meter per hour.
And that's why we don't go
into orbit around each other.
Okay?
Because you're always moving way,
way,
way faster than the escape velocity
of the people you're interacting with.
Uh,
the escape philosophy,
your earth is 10 kilometers a second,
so you're not moving that fast,
so you're bound to the earth.
But,
uh,
when you're a hanging
around with your friends,
you're probably going faster
than one meter per hour.
Uh,
and,
uh,
therefore you're moving faster
than the escape velocity.
You don't feel a great effect
of the gravitational force,
uh,
of other people.
This is kind of an anti
Valentine's Day calculation,
right?
Because it proves that human beings
are not attracted to each other,
uh,
at least not by the force of gravity.
Uh,
and so you can do this
calculation for any given object.
Fine.
So what's a black hole?
Black hole has actually
a very simple definition.
A black hole is simply something,
uh,
in which the escape velocity is greater
than or equal to the speed of light.
C is the,
uh,
expression for the seat of speed of life.
This is three times 10 to
the eight meters per second.
Uh,
and if you've got something where,
uh,
the escape philosophy is
great in the speed of light,
that's what a black hole is,
and it makes a certain amount of sense.
If the escape velocity is
greater than the speed of light,
then a light won't escape this object.
So you won't be able to see it,
right?
Because the way you see something is
you see the photons that come off it.
Uh,
and there's nothing
particularly extraordinary
about this as far as it goes.
Uh,
in fact,
uh,
in the middle of this was already,
talked about and worked out in some detail
in the middle of the 18th century by
an otherwise obscure,
uh,
English clergyman named
I think John Mitchell.
And,
uh,
he did the following calculation.
He said,
okay,
now,
uh,
if this is going to be true,
how big is such an object?
How dance doesn't have to be,
and you can work this out.
Uh,
supposing the v the escape philosophy
is equal to the speed of light.
So C is equal to two g m
over r to the one half power.
Uh,
you can square both sides and regroup and
you have R is equal to two g m oversee
square.
This is now,
it wasn't called this in the 18th century,
but it's now called the
Schwartz Shield radius.
[inaudible]
was a contemporary of Einstein's.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this is the size something has to be in
order for it to escape velocity to be
equal to the speed of light.
And a black hole in another definition
of a black hole is something in which the
radius of the object is less
than the Schwarzman radius.
Because if the radius is less,
then the escape velocity
will be even greater.
So as I say,
this was worked out in obscurity in the
middle of the 18th century and nobody
thought anything much about it.
Mitchell sort of pondered for a little
bit what touch an object would look like.
And he decided it would look dark,
uh,
and,
and true enough,
uh,
but who cares?
Uh,
and,
uh,
nobody thought anything further
about it for 150 years until,
uh,
Einstein came along at the
start of the 20th century and,
uh,
came up with the theory of relativity
and one the pieces important pieces of,
of relativity is that the speed of light,
this c is a very,
very special velocity and has a
rather bizarre and extremely profound
properties.
And it was only at that point that,
uh,
the concept of the black
hole was recognized as
something that was in any way
out of the ordinary.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so for 150 years,
this idea kind of lay dormant,
uh,
until it was resurrected by a profound
change in the thinking about the
underlying physics.
Uh,
so this is one of these
kinds of historical fables
that we've hit a couple of
times.
This is the fable of,
uh,
Mitchell's,
discovery
of black holes.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
the moral of this little fable might be
that the importance of a result changes
depending on the context.
Oh,
result
changes.
Yeah.
Sometimes dramatically,
uh,
with context.
So something that looks quite
unimportant for a long time,
all of a sudden become a very big deal.
Uh,
and so it happened in this case.
Okay.
So how,
one question you can ask is,
uh,
that's all fine.
How big is the Schwab chilled radius for,
for some bunch of objects?
Let's try the sun.
Uh,
here,
let me start a new piece of paper.
So how
big is the Schwab trilled
radius of the sun?
Uh,
swatch of radius again,
two g m oversee squared equal two times
seven times 10 to the minus 11 mass of
the Sun.
Now two times 10 to the
30 divided by c squared,
C is three times 10 to the eight.
Okay.
And we'll square it.
Okay,
so let's see.
Uh,
two times two is four times seven is 30,
uh,
30 times 10 to the 1930 minus 11 is
19 divided by three times three is 10.
Uh,
10 to the eight squared is 10 to the 16.
So that's three times 10 to the
three because 19 minus 16 is three.
Oh in meters because
we're still in mks units.
Cause that's what we're,
uh,
using.
Uh,
that's the units of that
we've chosen great times,
10 to the three meters,
that's three kilometers.
That's a pretty small for the sun.
Uh,
and so you might imagine that,
uh,
such objects are,
are rare or perhaps even nonexistent
because it would have to be incredibly
small and therefore incredibly dense to
have a strong enough gravitational field
to prevent light from escaping.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
you might've thought that this is
an entirely theoretical concept,
and that no matter how interesting it is,
a,
there's no point in really studying and
get further because you're unlikely to
ever encounter one of
these things in real life.
Uh,
but one of the strange things that was,
uh,
has been known for quite some time is
that black holes really should exist,
uh,
and that they are predicted to exist.
And this has been known for quite a
while known for at least 70 years,
70 years,
uh,
that black holes
should exist.
Okay.
And the reason they
should is that they are,
uh,
one of the possible end
points of stellar evolution,
the evolution of stars.
And so now I want to
summarize how stars evolve.
I should say this is the
subject of a whole courses.
You can take a astro,
uh,
three 50,
and they will talk about
this for the entire semester.
Uh,
you can take astro one 10 and
they'll talk about it for a month.
Uh,
but we're going to do
it in about 20 minutes.
Uh,
say save you time and effort here.
so,
uh,
Star's life is determined by the
competition between two forces.
Uh,
so stars a lifetime and evolution,
uh,
is determined
by two forces.
One is gravity,
which has the tendency to
hold the star together.
Uh,
and now the thing about gravity is,
uh,
it ought to work.
Uh,
the stars have no solid surface.
So if you can imagine gravity pulling
on an atom on the surface of the star,
why should that Adam just fall all the
way down to the bottom of the star,
uh,
because there is no solid surface
to prevent it from doing so.
Uh,
and the answer is that gravity
isn't the only force operating.
There's also pressure.
So there's gravity,
uh,
which pulls stuff in and pressure,
which has the tendency to push out and
these things balance in most stars in the
sun for example,
these two forces are in balance
at all points in the sun.
And this balance goes
by the technical name,
a hydro static equilibrium.
Okay.
Uh,
hydro because it's a fluid,
it's not a solid surface static,
nothing's moving.
And equilibrium is just balance.
And to be a little more
precise the way this works,
here's the,
here's the surface of some star.
Uh,
here's some point within the star and
there are two kinds forces acting on this
point.
There's a gravity which is pulling the
thing toward the center of the star.
And then there's pressure forces,
uh,
in two different ways.
Uh,
the outer regions of the
star exert a pressure inward.
So there's an inward pressure and the
inner regions of the star exerted pressure
outward.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the outward pressure has to be greater
than the inward pressure by exactly the
right amount to counteract gravity.
So it basically looks like pee
out minus P N is equal to gravity.
And this holds true at all points.
Now in order,
uh,
it's the other way round.
Right?
Thank you.
P in minus p out.
Yeah.
Right.
P in minus p out has to equal gravity and
that requires that the pressure on the
inside has to be bigger than the pressure
on the outside because you don't have
negative gravity.
Uh,
at least not until the
third part of this course.
Uh,
but at the moment you don't
have any negative gravity.
And so,
uh,
the pressure on the inside has to be
greater than the pressure on the outside.
Okay.
So what is pressure?
Uh,
cast your mind back to
high school chemistry.
I remember high school chemistry
doesn't matter if you don't,
I'll tell you everything you need to know.
There's something called
an ideal gas and uh,
there's something that the ideal gas does,
which is to exert gas pressure.
Uh,
your high school chemistry
teacher probably wrote down
something that looks like
this Pv equals an r t.
Uh,
and uh,
here's the thing about,
about this vias volume.
In this case,
p is the pressure and is the,
uh,
number of particles
per volume.
And so the key thing here is that,
uh,
in divided by V is equal to the density
basically times a constant cause.
Remember,
uh,
density is mass per volume.
If you take the number of particles
and you multiply by the mass,
if each particle that'll give you the
total amount of mass and he'd give him
region,
you divide by the volume,
that equals the density.
And so this also is a constant,
this ar thing.
And so what you get is p is equal to
a constant times the density times the
temperature.
So this is how physicists think of the
ideal gas law because we prefer to work
in terms of the density.
Okay?
So here's,
here's the pressure and the pressure on
the inside had better be bigger than the
pressure on the outside or
this isn't going to balance,
which means either the density or the
temperature or both had better be larger
in the middle of the star than it
is in the outer parts of the star.
So inside
of the star,
the t ant or the row has to be
bigger than it is on the outside.
Now turns out that if you just keep the
temperature constant all the way through
the star,
you never achieve this balance.
Uh,
so if only the density varies,
then you enter regions do
have a higher pressure,
okay.
But the increase in density also increases
the force of gravity because gravity
is dependent on how much mass there is.
And if you increase the density,
you also increase the amount of mass.
Uh,
so you have higher pressure,
but you also have higher gravity.
And it turns out,
uh,
that you can prove
mathematically speaking that uh,
no balance is possible because
it's always ends up being the case,
uh,
for gas pressure,
that the amount you have to increase
the density by if you're only increasing
the density,
uh,
will also increase the gravity
and you'll never get it balanced.
So the consequence of that is that the
inner parts of a star must be hotter
then the outer parts,
otherwise the star wouldn't exist.
It would collapse.
Ma'Am.
This is true.
The inside of the sun
turns out to be something
like 10 to the seven degrees.
Okay.
The surface of the sun.
Yeah.
Uh,
turns out to be something like
six times 10 to the three degrees.
So yes,
indeed the inside very
much hotter than the sun.
Very much hotter than
the outside in the sun.
And that's what keeps the sun in balance.
And there's a problem with this.
And the problem is that there,
there's,
uh,
something called thermodynamics.
And one of the laws of thermodynamics is
that he tends to flow from places where
it's hot to places where it's cool.
Uh,
this is evident in everyday life.
If you take a little piece of,
I don't know,
molten lead or something,
and you drop it in a bucket of water,
the heat from the led will
spread into the water.
The water will increase in
temperature very slightly.
The heat will come out
of that piece of led.
The led will solidify and,
uh,
everything will come into a
kind of temperature balance.
Similarly,
if you put a snowball and,
uh,
some hot place,
it'll melt.
Why?
Because the heat from,
uh,
from around,
we'll go into the snow ball.
Uh,
the temperatures will,
uh,
try and equalize each other and bell,
it'll come out even.
So this,
uh,
law of thermodynamics is why the
snowball has no chance in hell.
Uh,
and uh,
so this is happens in stars too,
right?
Uh,
so the heat in the center of the star,
yeah.
It flows out.
Yeah.
When it gets to the surface,
it's radiated
at the surface.
It radiate a,
and that's the energy that we see coming
from the star is this heat that was in
the center.
It's gotten to the surface.
It's now radiating away out
into the cold depths of space.
And that's what we see.
But that means that the temperature
in the center of the star,
which is holding the star up decreases
and then the star wouldn't hold itself
up.
So you require in order for the star
to hold itself out and energy source.
Yeah.
At the center of the star.
This does two things.
It replaces all that last heat.
Yeah.
Uh,
and it preserves
okay.
The equilibrium of the star
so it doesn't collapse.
Yeah.
Okay.
So this is all pretty abstract.
Uh,
and it was known that this had to be
true before they figured out what the
energy source was.
It was known for,
uh,
people just sort of thinking in very
general terms about how the Sun could
exist,
understood that there had to be some kind
of large source of energy down in the
middle of the star.
And notice it has to be
in the middle of the star.
It does.
No good for the energy to be created
all the way through the star because if
it's created all the way through the star,
uh,
then,
the temperature is distributed throughout
the star and you don't get a situation
where it's much hotter in the
middle than it is on the outside.
So everybody knew for quite a while that
there was energy being created in the
center of the story.
They just didn't understand
how that was done.
Uh,
and then when people
invented nuclear physics,
uh,
in the 1930s and forties and 50s,
it was understood that this
comes from nuclear reactions,
nuclear fusion in particular,
in the case of the sun,
it's the fusion of hydrogen atoms
together to make helium that does this and
that releases energy.
And the same way that a nuclear bomb does,
the problem with this is that eventually
you run out of hydrogen or whatever
your nuclear fuel is because you've got
only a limited amount of it in any one
star.
So eventually
the nuclear fuel runs out
and then the star has
many adventures,
uh,
before it settles down.
And,
uh,
for these,
I will have to refer you either to a
textbook or to some other course because
I'm not going to take
you through the whole,
uh,
exciting life of a star wants
its nuclear fuel is exhausted.
Suffice it to say that you know,
in advance what the outcome has to be
because there's no way it can hold itself
up in the long run because it doesn't
have an energy source down at the center
of the star.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the consequence of this has
to be that the star collapses.
Okay?
Now,
it doesn't necessarily collapse all the
way down to being a black hole because
there are other kinds of pressure besides
the pressure exerted by an ideal gas.
So at very high densities,
okay?
You get other kinds of pressure.
Okay.
In particular,
there's some king called a electron,
okay?
Degeneracy pressure
is sometimes called fair me pressure
after the guy who thought it up,
okay?
Degeneracy is another one of those words
that means something different to a
physicist than they do to ordinary,
normal people.
Uh,
so I remember the first
time I taught astro one 10,
uh,
right after,
I came here about 15 years ago.
I started talking in the middle of a
class about degenerate white dwarfs.
And you could feel this sort of wave of,
uh,
something between confusion and,
and,
and anxiety permeate through the class.
And I had no idea what was going on.
Some teaching assistant had
to pull me aside afterwards.
Remind me that these words
mean different things.
So I apologize if this sounds like a,
a sort of adult version
of a Grimms fairy tale,
you know,
with degenerate white dwarfs,
wandering around and stuff,
but such or such are the
words we have to work with.
Uh,
okay.
So you have this electron degeneracy
pressure that's a different kind of
pressure and that can stabilize
the star so it stabilizes a star,
stabilizes the store at,
around the radius of the earth.
So that very high density material,
we can calculate the density.
You'll remember our equation
for density mass over volume.
Uh,
and so let's see,
how does this work?
Uh,
this will be the mass of the sun.
Let's say divided by
the volume of the earth,
that's four thirds.
Pi r cubed radius severest
seven times 10 to the six cubed.
Uh,
so let's see,
uh,
two times 10 to the 30th over,
four,
seven cube seven squared
is 57 cubed is 350,
um,
times 10 to the 18 at six times three.
Yeah.
Okay.
We're doing all right.
Uh,
and let's say that that's
2000 times 10 to the 27 over,
I dunno,
1400 times 10 to the 18
went to cancel those,
uh,
10 to the nine kilograms
per meter squared.
That's about a million
times denser than water
watering.
Your members tend to the three
kilograms per meter square
than water.
Water,
uh,
is defined to have a density of
one gram per cubic centimeter.
So if you were to pick up one gram of
this white dwarf of one cubic centimeter
of just white dwarf,
it would be a million times
more massive than a gram.
That's about a ton.
So a thimble full of this stuff,
uh,
weighs about a ton,
very dense,
uh,
and the sun will end its life as a
white dwarf with the select pressure,
uh,
balancing the gravity
and these such stars
are called white dwarfs
and there are many of them known
like dwarfs.
This is the end point of the sun.
Okay.
And then in the 1930s,
what happened,
uh,
to make black holes inevitable,
was that,
uh,
one of the Great Theoretical
astrophysicist of the 20th century,
a man named Subramanian Chandra Sacar,
uh,
discovered that electron degeneracy
pressure doesn't always do the job.
So in the 1930s,
a chanter sacar
discovers,
proves,
uh,
that if the mass of an object is greater
than 1.4 times the mass of the sun,
uh,
electron,
this kind of electron
pressure is insufficient
and the star continues to collapse.
Now,
uh,
Chandra was a graduate student
in England at the time.
He figured this out and he presented
this rather dramatic result at a big
meeting of the Royal
Astronomical Society in London.
And then,
uh,
every graduate student's
worst nightmare took place.
Uh,
Chandra's thesis advisor was a very
famous man named Arthur Eddington,
one of the great physicists
of the early 20th century.
And after Chandra had presented
his results to all these,
uh,
assembled scientific dignitaries,
Addington got up and denounced
his own student and said,
this can't possibly be true.
And Addington made the famous remark,
there ought to be a law of
nature to prevent stars from
behaving in this foolish
manner.
Uh,
and uh,
and the consequence of that is that
a lot of people didn't follow up on
Chandra's a idea.
Chandra got miffed,
as you might understand,
he got on the boat to the,
uh,
to the United States.
He spent the rest of his career at
the University of Chicago on the boat.
He wrote a great textbook still in use
on the structure of stars in which you
laid out in detail all of the
arguments that the chapter sake,
our limit must actually exist.
And,
uh,
50 years later he got
the Nobel prize for it,
but that there was this
kind of time lag there.
Uh,
and it is I think,
important for those of us say on the
faculty to recall that if Eddington had
listened to his student
instead of to his intuition,
uh,
the study of black holes would probably
be 40 years more advanced than it is.
So,
uh,
another fable for our times,
Chandra was always very
gracious about this actually.
He would praise,
uh,
Addington to the skies
as a wonderful advisor.
And then with this,
a little asterisk,
uh,
so fable Chandra [inaudible] Chandra say
cars limit is the title and the moral
here is a belief your student,
not your intuition.
Uh,
and actually
the story of Edington was
actually kind of interesting.
As Eddington got older,
he became more and more convinced that,
uh,
you know,
he could guess the right answer.
Uh,
and so it wasn't just
the chatter sacred limit,
it was other things.
He got a little weird toward the end of
his life and he started believing his
intuition.
Einstein did this too,
right?
Einstein famously discovers
all this great stuff,
and then the second half of his life
has completely useless scientifically
because he becomes convinced,
uh,
that his gut is telling him
that quantum mechanics is wrong.
Uh,
this famous remark,
God does not play dice with the universe.
Uh,
but it turns out that isn't true.
And so,
uh,
you know,
there is this probabilistic,
uh,
nature of reality that
quantum mechanics shows.
And so Einstein spent the second half
of his life trying to prove that his
intuition was correct.
The quantum mechanics
couldn't really be true,
and thus did no physics worth
doing for about 30 or 40 years.
Uh,
so you have to watch out for this.
If you're too smart and
start believing yourself,
you can get into trouble.
Um,
all right.
Uh,
now having to settle that
Eddington was partly right.
There is sort of a law of nature that
prevents stars from behaving in this
foolish manner.
Uh,
so,
uh,
to understand that what
happens when white dwarfs,
uh,
when the white dwarf collapses,
it's got to get rid of its electrons.
Because the problem is the way this
electron degeneracy pressure works.
You can't squeeze electrons
any closer together.
Uh,
then they are a white dwarf.
So now you have to get rid of electrons.
And so what are you do?
You combine the electrons and the protons
and you turn them into neutrons plus
neutrinos.
These are neutrinos.
They stream out.
And so,
uh,
you end up with something that's
made entirely out of neutrons,
saw the whole star,
uh,
turns into neutrons.
Uh,
a chemist would think of
this as essentially turning
the whole star into one
Adam into one atomic nucleus and atomic
nucleus with no PR on a Tom and Adam
with no protons,
no electrons,
and tend to the 57 neutrons.
And you could imagine,
you know,
putting that somewhere
on the periodic table,
uh,
astronomers call these
things neutron stars,
and they exist.
They were discovered in the 1960s.
Okay.
And a typical neutron star,
a couple times the mass of the sun,
uh,
has,
mass equals two times the mass of the
sun radius of about 10 kilometers.
And you can work out the density for
that density is a billion times greater.
I'll leave this as an exercise,
uh,
greater than for white dwarfs.
So instead of a cubic centimeter
of the stuff weighing a ton,
it now weighs a billion tons a and you're
having a tough time moving it around,
but 10 kilometers that getting close
to their Schwab chilled radius.
Remember we calculated the
truck showed radius of the sun.
It was about three kilometers.
And in fact,
if you calculate a,
the shark shield radius of a star in
terms of the Schwartz Shield radius of the
sun,
uh,
let's see,
you get to g m oversee squared where m
is the mass of the star divided by two g
mass of the sun oversee squared.
Uh,
so the g's and the C's all cancel
here and you get m star over m son.
So
if the chanter sake,
our mass of the sun is
equal to three kilometers.
As we calculated,
uh,
the,
Schwab chilled radius of a star with
whose mass happens to equal three times,
the mass of the sun is going to be three
times 10 kilometers or 10 kilometers
that equal to the radius
of a neutron star.
So a neutron star
with mass greater than three times the
mass of the sun has a radius less than at
Schwab children.
Yes.
And that's a black hole.
I remember,
uh,
and uh,
the thi the key thing here is that there
are lots of stars with mass more than
three times the mass of the sun.
We don't see them as black holes
because they're still in hydrostatic
equilibrium,
but eventually they're going to run out
of nuclear fuel and they're going to
collapse.
Now,
in fact,
during the course of,
of the star's life,
one of the things I glossed over
is stars tend to lose masses.
They live,
uh,
and so they don't end up with
the same mass they started with,
but stars with initial masses at
the beginning of their lifetime,
a greater than,
Oh,
I dunno,
something like 30 times
the mass of this done son.
We'll end up with masses greater
than three times the mass of the sun.
And then there's nothing
to stop their collapse.
What happens is they
turn into neutron stars,
but they turn into neutron stars,
whose truck showed radius,
who's ready.
I are smaller than the
Schwab showed radius.
And that,
uh,
is a black hole,
so they collapsed down into black holes.
And so you expect a large number
of black holes to actually exist.
This is what happens to massive
stars at the end of their life.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
we expect
there to be that there are,
okay.
Manny
black holes.
Okay.
And so the question we'll be exploring
in the rest of this segment of the class
is how can you find these things,
uh,
what are the properties of these things
from a theoretical point of view,
what does Einstein's theory of relativity
suggests that these things are going
to behave like?
And then the,
the big question is,
once you found some,
and you have a theory for
what they behave like,
then you can ask the question,
does the actual behavior of these
objects that conform to the theoretical
expectations?
Another way of saying that is,
was Einstein,
right?
Is General relativity the correct theory
to describe these very exotic objects.
And so that's what we'll be talking
about in the rest of this section of the
courts.
Now,
let me turn back to the
previous section of the course,
which was,
uh,
which culminated last
time in this little test.
Uh,
and,
uh,
I think we're ready to hand these back.
Is that true?